bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir
nous allons parler de la ruralité dans
les yvelines quels sont les enjeux pour
les zones rurales dans les années à
venir
quels sont les besoins des habitants les
préoccupations également des habitants
c'est à ces questions que nous allons
tenter de répondre ce soir et c'est pour
répondre à ces questions également que
le département des yvelines a lancé il
ya plusieurs mois les assises de la
ruralité nous allons évoquer le sujet
avec nos invités pauline vinokourov
lefebvre vice président du conseil
départemental délégué aux ruralité
philippe g cela maire de méricourt et
président de l'union des maires ruraux
des yvelines lucille méthé talent chargé
d'études excusez-moi l'institut
d'aménagement et d'urbanisme d'île de
france et enfin françois lecoq
agriculteur et membre des jeunes
agriculteurs d'ile-de-france bonsoir à
vous quatre et avant de se lancer dans
ce débat un point avec vous pauline
aveeno pour lefebvre sur ces assises de
la ruralité c'est un processus qui a été
lancé à l'automne dernier
on voit les chiffres apparaître à
l'écran et 30 rencontres en tout 2000
participants et 500 contributions
pourquoi vous avez eu l'idée
initialement de lancer ces assises de la
ruralité est ce que le département ce
que la majorité au sein du conseil
départemental
les élus ne connaissais pas bien les
besoins des zones rurales du monde rural
résister si les élus ruraux connaissent
est d'autant plus les besoins d
des zones rurales qu'on sortait d'une
campagne électorale donc on en avait un
peu entendu parler sur le terrain mais
l'idée était de répondre le mieux
possible aux besoins des habitants dans
le contexte de restrictions budgétaires
qui est le nôtre et il nous a paru utile
d'aller à l'ecoute des habitants et des
acteurs de ces territoires pour avec le
plus pertinent possible dans les
réponses qu'on pouvait leur apporter
et vous avez eu ainsi des contributions
500 précisément et parmi les propos que
les préoccupations majeures qui sont
ressortis on a en numéro 1 on le voit
aussi à l'écran les déplacements le
numéro de haut débit endroit lien social
en 4 l'emploi et puis en 5
l'urbanisation avec les déplacements
largement devant puisque ses 51% des
personnes qui ont contribué à cette
enquête qui ont mentionné les
déplacements c'est quelque chose qui
vous a surpris ce classement ces
informations là où alors vous les
connaissiez également d'ailleurs on
imaginait bien que c'était les sujets
essentiels avec des variantes selon les
territoires sur lesquels se tenaient les
réunions mais on savait que c'était
c'était des sujets essentiels pour les
pour les habitants de nos territoires
ruraux on a des axes de transport saturé
des transports en commun suffisant voilà
donc on s'y attendait un peu
mais
aujourd'hui vous avez les moyens de
répondre à ces problèmes précise oui
alors on va on répondra pas à tous les
problèmes qui ont été évoqués c'est pas
possible c'est pas forcément de
compétences et en revanche dans les
échanges qu'on a pu avoir avec les
habitants il ya eu quelques propositions
d'initiatives qui pourrait répondre aux
problèmes d'accessibilité au garrot
problèmes de transport notamment sur le
développement d'api de covoiturage ou
ou deux
de d'auto-stop organiser des choses
comme ça que le département pourrait
appuyer sur lesquels on pourra être
moteur monsieur amédée talent quand vous
voyez aussi vous ce classement avec le
déplacement numéro 1 51 % des gens qui
mentionne que c'est leur priorité numéro
un
justement ensuite on a le haut débit le
lien social l'emploi l'organisation vous
experts de sujets là ça ne vous surprend
pas non plus c'est ce que vous voyez au
quotidien non ça ne me surprend pas en
appel mais au moins quelques tendances à
ces nouvelles concernant la mobilité qui
sont intéressantes à observer et
notamment une stabilisation des
distances domicile travail pour les
habitants de ces territoires périurbains
et ruraux usage de la voiture aussi qui
se stabilise
là où elle n'avait de cesse que de
progresser depuis des années et des
années
et puis principalement un recentrage des
activités hors travail un recentrage des
activités quelles que soient les motifs
achats loisirs et vie sociale autour du
lieu de résidence dont avec des
distances qui l ont tendance à diminuer
comme ça on voit plus au sein de
l'agglomération ou du monde urbain pour
faire ses activités culturelles sociales
après le travail on fait ça prenne chez
soi ou à des habitants qui ont un peu
tendance à tourner le dos dans leur vie
à cette agglomération à mieux explorer
le territoire de la proximité et un
retour du local de la localité une
nouvelle appétence pour les commerces de
proximité qui s'observe à la fois dans
nos enquêtes quantitatives mais qui fait
bien et qu aussi à ce que nous ont
raconté les habitants lors des enquêtes
qualitatives et cette quête de proximité
elle s'observe aussi dans une
fréquentation plus importante des
espaces naturels une appropriation de
ces espaces naturels qui font partie
vraiment du mode de vie des habitants
là où il ya quelques années dans nos
enquêtes
c'est la maison qui venait en premier
cercle finalement ont quitté la ville
pour avoir une maison et de l'espace au
sein de cette maison mais
l'environnement était peut citer dans
les choix résidentiels et dans les
motivations
aujourd'hui il
essentiel le les espaces de nature font
partie de ce mode de vie on va continuer
le tour de table avec vous philippe
geste lent alors vous êtes maire de
méricourt et puis aussi président de
l'union des maires ruraux des yvelines
vous aussi les déplacements le haut
débit c'est ce qu'on vous dit en premier
j'imagine cd de critères qui arrive en
premier alors je veux saluer tout de
suite l'initiative qu'a pris le
département d'organiser ces assises de
la ruralité
tout ce qui concourt l'amélioration de
la vie de nos habitants évidemment une
bonne chose
voilà donc on voit bien au travers de ce
qui est ressorti ses des préoccupations
soit c'est le déplacement nous on a
trois types d'habitants dans nos
communes
on a les habitants qui sont là de
génération en génération compte toujours
vécu dans les communes qui sont habitués
à ce mode de vie qui travaillent en
général à proximité souvent dans
l'agriculture ou dans les commerces
locaux
après comme vous ne l'avez dit les
habitants qui viennent par un choix de
vie parce que c'est le cadre de vie
c'est s'approprier la nature c'est un
peu un retour aux sources
notre mode de consommation etc et puis
on a une troisième catégorie d'habitants
qui sont plutôt des urbains ou des
périodes robin à proximité de la grande
couronne qui viennent chez nous un peu
par obligation ou j'appelle ça la fuite
vers l'ouest on vient habiter à la
campagne parce que c'est moins cher
dans un premier temps et puis on trouve
que c'est sympa quoi était il fait beau
les petits oiseaux chantent etc
mais malgré tout on continue à
travailler sur la capitale ou en proche
banlieue et avoir deux heures et demie
de transport le matin deux heures et
demie le soir pour rentrer à maison
gérer les enfants qu'on a laissé à
l'école communale
voilà c'est pas simple et donc tout ce
qui peut améliorer les déplacements de
ses habitants pour leur permettre
évidemment d'aller au travail dans une
position bien c'est une bonne chose
alors le fait que les différents profils
comme ça quand vous les définissez ça
complique aussi la tâche puisque les
besoins ne sont pas les mêmes les
attentes ne sont pas les mêmes on n'a
pas affaire ici à un type de population
ah non non non pas du tout alors c'est
sûr que c'est nous ces nouveaux
habitants pour nous on doit s'adapter on
doit réinventer notre réalité c'est
difficile de les faire participer à la
vie communale aujourd'hui nous on a un
tissu associatif dans nos communes qui
est assez développée et le week-end ils
sont un peu claqué quoi nous on a du mal
mais petit à petit on y arrive à les
associer à des manifestations
évidemment dans nos communes il ya
beaucoup de bénévolat que ce soit les
comités des fêtes et la maison des arts
enfin plein de choses et voilà on y
arrive et on y arrive au travers de
l'école puisque c'est l'école qui crée
le lien c'est un lieu de rencontre c'est
un lieu de vie dans nos noms dans nos
petites communes il n'y a plus beaucoup
de commerces donc le lien c'est l'école
donc c'est à partir de là qu'on arrive à
les fédérer allait rassembler les
intéressés à nos vies
françois lecoq qu'on termine ce premier
tour de table avec vous vous êtes
agriculteur donc vous travaillez dans le
monde rural vous y vivez aussi beaucoup
j'imagine que pour vous la priorité
c'est pas forcément les déplacements
c'est aussi une inquiétude pour le pour
nous le déplacement parce que on se
doute que ont fait venir des populations
de plus en plus nombreuses sur les
yvelines il faudra bien que ces gens
elle puisse aller travailler on a peur
tous les ans nous perdons déjà 1500
hectares de terres agricoles au niveau
ile de france
s'il faut reconstruire des routes des
voies de chemin de fer ou des déviations
bien entendu que notre outil de travail
est en danger donc le un des avantages
qui a eu ce que tous ces débats
participatifs sont toujours un petit peu
inquiets tant pour l'agriculture un
point intéressant a été le fait de
pouvoir discuter avec les populations de
nos villages qui ont toujours un a
priori sur notre métier
donc ça ça a été aussi un moment des
changes qui est très important
aujourd'hui les habitants des zones
rurales ont des a priori sur sur les
aviculteurs oui oui ça va ça va plaire
normalement les gens ont des a priori
parce que aujourd'hui la les médias leur
font voir une certaine agriculture qui
est pas forcément celle qui voit à côté
de chez eux alors le but de ces assises
pour les minots pour le faible c'est de
cerner les préoccupations des habitants
et de tenter d'y répondre vous avez
évoqué le sujet vous a commencé pour les
transports quelle mesure on peut mettre
en place concrètement assez rapidement
pour répondre aux besoins des habitants
si vous avez su ou pu aussi décerné
précisément les besoins là si on les
transporte sur les sentiments alors
rapidement ses appels se faire du jour
au lendemain parce que c'était des
choses simples à mettre en oeuvre et sur
les idées c'est pas mal non plus sur des
promesses pouvoir et non et puis ça
n'aurait pas de sens et surtout sur les
transports il ya plusieurs il faut faire
plusieurs choses c'est à dire qu'il ya
on a un programme de
pour intervenir sur les parkings relais
au niveau des gares pour les
redimensionner pour que ce soit des
vrais espaces intermodaux mais il faut
aussi qu'on ait des solutions de
covoiturage pour aller vers ces parkings
pour pas que chacun prenne sa voiture et
se mettre sur le parking parce que sinon
on aura beau le redis mentionné ce sera
jamais suffisant donc c'est une
multitude de solutions qu'il faut mener
en même temps pour pour répondre aux
attentes qu'on prétend qu'on n'aura pas
un arrêt de bus ou une gare de métro en
bas de chez soi de mes troupes et du
tout du reste je pense au grand paris
express parce que qui avec le métro qui
va arriver dans les yvelines avec la
ligne 18 dans le futur mais concrètement
on n'aura pas de ligne de bus qui
avouera pour tout le monde donc à près
de chez soi il y en a qui passent un oui
bien sûr jamais sur les transports par
exemple un gros sujet qu'on a eue au
travers des échanges qu'on a pu avoir
avec les principaux de collèges ou avec
des collégiens directement c'est les
transports des élèves en dehors des
heures arrivée des cols sortie d'école
dont qui sont sur des lignes de bus
régulières ou des lignes de bus scolaire
mais si leurs cours démarrent plus tard
s'il ya un prof absent longtemps et soit
ils attendent à l'école soit ils n'ont
pas de solution pour y aller voilà donc
là dessus on pourrait développer du
covoiturage entre parents d'élèves et
c'est un projet qui a été qui va être
mis en oeuvre à travers les ce qu'on
appelle les espaces où les
environnements pardon numérique de
travail qui sont dédiés au collet aux
collégiens aux profs et aux parents
d'élèves
on pourrait mettre en place d une appli
de covoiturage dédié aux collégiens pour
qu'en dehors des heures
dites de pointe ou que le mercredi au
moment des temps périscolaires il est du
covoiturage entre entre parents de
collégiens qui peuvent philippe g cela
puis lucille méthé talent philippe
gestion vous êtes le maire d'une commune
de 400 habitants est ce que ce type de
réponse ça correspond à vos besoins au
manque de transports en commun dans vos
communes il ya un manque de transports
en commun ça c'est certain mais ce
serait un non sens de faire circuler des
bus de 50 places dans nos communes qui
tournerait pour les trois quarts à vide
donc je pense qu'il faut réinventer des
nouveaux modes de transport dans le
commune par exemple le transport à la
demande type un peu hubert ou sous
d'autres formes l'auto-stop organiser le
covoiturage
je pense que c'est la multitude des des
actions qui va qui va désengorger un
petit peu les neurones parce que on
n'aura pas les moyens je pense de créer
de nouvelles infrastructures s'est
d'ailleurs pas souhaitable il ya un
projet de 2
lnpn la ligne paris normandie voilà qui
est sous jacent actuellement qui va
poser un certain nombre de soucis à nos
amis agriculteurs puisqu'un km2 de voix
je crois que ces dix hectares de
consommer donc voilà développer les
infrastructures à mon avis c'est bon
c'est pas trop envisagé en plus il ya
plus d'argent donc je pense qu'il faut
changer nos modes de déplacement tout
simplement réinventer les choses il faut
qu'on arrive à lâcher notre voiture donc
la prise de conscience peut venir aussi
des citoyens en lui-même en premier le
village en sachant que là dans nos
territoires périurbains et ruraux et si
on prend que les communes rurales les
petites communes rurales un quart des
déplacements sont des déplacements de
proximité de moins de 5 km et l'enjeu
c'est peut-être de réconcilier la
proximité et l'accessibilité est vrai qu
on pense souvent au domicile travail à
cette mobilité incompressible est assez
longue distance et aussi tout ce qui
relève de la vie quotidienne accompagner
les enfants à lire j'aime visites etc
et c'est vrai qu'il ya de la proximité
il ya parfois des problèmes
d'accessibilité parce que des ruptures
routière ou des ruptures agricole qui ne
permettent pas en fait de circuler à
pied ou à vélo
alors que le foncier existe même si
c'est compliqué le foncier mais il est a
priori assez généreux pour favoriser ces
mots doux vous pensez à quoi des pistes
cyclables il faudrait développer ce type
d'actions par exemple en faisant écho à
cette appétence pour la proximité et à
cette envie en fait de de faire de son
lieu de vie un vrai espace de vie qu'on
explore et qu'on fréquente et avec cette
appétence souci pour les mots doux
qu'expriment les habitants il ya
vraiment un enjeu d'aménagement en
termes de sécurité est passée de la
pratique de loisirs qui existe à une
vraie pratique quotidienne françois
lecoq
je suis un petit peu étonné parce qu'on
parle de covoiturage mais en fait on en
train de ressortir des vieux système
dans le temps mon grand père en est son
voisin chercher du pain donc aujourd'hui
faut organiser sa part des applications
numériques alors cela devrait se faire
ça devrait se faire naturellement les
gens devraient parler à leurs voisins de
l'autre côté de la clôture
sauf que certaines populations
qu'on ne voit dans nos villages arrive
est la première chose qu'ils font c'est
de laisser monter les murs de trois
mètres ou des haies de thuyas pour se
cacher derrière donc on vient à la
campagne mais on retrouve maintenant à
la campagne un certain isolement des
gens comme si j'étais un appartement à
paris
globalement je voulais vous voulez vous
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure en
disant qu'il fallait que les maires et
les élus s'adapte aux besoins de ces
nouveaux habitants mais je pense qu'il
faut aussi que les nouveaux habitants
s'adapte au mode de vie à la campagne et
st jean ce que vous disiez sur sûr je
pense notamment à une des réunions
publiques qu on a tenu
nous on avait un jeune habitant qui
arrivaient des hauts-de-seine et qu'ils
n'envisageaient pas la possibilité de
faire du covoiturage ou demandé à son
voisin comment lui s'arrangeait pour
emmener ses enfants jeux pour accepter
sur du périscolaire
c'était quelque chose on peut le
comprendre il venait il avait toujours
été urbain c'est pas des modes de
fonctionnement urbain ne pouvait pas
l'envisager et du coup au travers de ces
réunions et des échanges qui a eu entre
différents types de populations de nos
communes rurales
certains se sont dit voilà on peut
peut-être aussi faire différemment parce
qu'on est dans un contexte différent et
ça permet d'en prendre conscience
donc c'est aussi aux habitants de
s'adapter et de chercher comment de
chercher à comprendre comment la
ruralité fonctionne ce qui veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui
s'installent dans nos zones rurales qui
veulent le confort des zones rurales
davantage de vivres dans les zones
rurales avec le cadre de vie la qualité
de vie et vimy mais qui veulent aussi le
confort d'une zone urbaine avec les
déplacements mais dans une forme de
paradoxe finalement vous n'avez pas
l'air d'accord avec sol
j'entends bien ce paradoxe mais pour
dire que c'est un mode de vie qui
s'apprend avec le temps fait son affaire
c'est à dire que quand on fait une
typologie des habitants les nouveaux
arrivants un moment donné ils sont plus
de nouveaux arrivants absolument et je
pense que c'est vraiment un mode de vie
qui nécessite un apprentissage et dans
les yvelines c'est vrai que la phase
d'explosion démographique était vraiment
loin derrière nous donc il ya un
tassement
il ya des gens qui sont la ville attend
depuis longtemps déjà dit on mais il ya
aussi une nouvelle ya aussi des
habitants qui sont venus là il ya 20 ans
30 ans par choix et aujourd'hui comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure des gens
qui viennent par contrainte et cette
ruralité subi leurs attentes ne sont pas
les mêmes
ils ont pas choisi le cadre de vie ils
sont venus là parce qu'il n'avait pas le
choix
et du coup ils veulent les mêmes
services que ceux de ces majorités de
gens aujourd'hui qui s'installe on va
dire par obligation dans les communes
rurales ou salaces une minorité ce que
vous savez c'est vous qui avez un regard
à une des secteurs mais nous y aller
parce qu'on peut quantifier ça il ya les
deux il ya les deux mais une chose est
sûre c'est que ceux qui font ça pour un
choix de vie pour une qualité de vie sa
taille très bien même si au début ils
sont très consommateurs de services on a
beaucoup de demandes
donc on doit mettre en place beaucoup de
pédagogie c'est plus compliqué à partir
du moment où vous tapez son porte
monnaie des services on peut tous sont
créés mais voilà quand il faut payer et
des danses année d'accord donc voilà à
force de discuter on trouve des
solutions tous ensemble on y arrive
enfin le bal moi je voulais juste
revenir sur le fait qu'il ya des gens
qui sont là depuis longtemps donc on
n'est pas prioritaire sur ce territoire
mais on doit aussi être respectées et
souvent on a l'impression c'est à nous
qui sommes déjà la fin je pense que
monsieur le maire comme contredire c'est
c'est à nous de nous adapter aux
nouveaux arrivants alors que c'est aux
nouveaux arrivants de s'adapter à ce qui
est déjà en place dans nos communes
et c'est là où la marché est inversé
globalement je voudrais vous parler d'un
autre sujet quand on quand on lit la
presse aujourd'hui quand des
spécialistes évoquent ce sujet sur les
plateaux télé aussi ce sujet de la
ruralité au moment des élections
notamment
on entend souvent qu'il ya un sentiment
d'abandon chez les habitants des zones
rurales les commerces qui ferment les
transports qui ne viennent pas le manque
de travail
est ce que cette idée est fausse et ce
que cette idée est exagéré philippe
geste lent mais bon c'est vrai ça de nom
c'est vrai que c'est un sentiment qu'on
n'explique pas toujours d'ailleurs mai
le constat il est là il ya plus de
commerces dans les petites communes ça
c'est sûr donc il faut essayer de
préserver ce qui reste et notamment des
communes de moyenne importance type 1500
habitants où vous avez aujourd'hui
encore un pharmacien à boulanger un café
etc
c'est le jour où le médecin partira de
cette commune l'a par exemple la
pharmacie fermera et voilà donc il faut
essayer de préserver sa sphère du
rabattement pas toujours sur les grandes
villes justement à propos du transport
mais faire du rabattement sur ces
communes de taille moyenne qui
permettent une petite vie locale sas et
je pense que c'est très important donc à
terme c'est la disparition des toutes
petites communes que vous prédisez plus
ou moins non c'est pas la disparition
pour ça des communes c'est la
disparition des commerces dans les
communes mais on va s'adapter à la
disparition veulent s'allier dans les
petites communes alors oui il faut
absolument se battre pour maintenir nos
écoles
mais effectivement si vous parlez de la
disparition des communes programmée par
par l'état par la technocratie
parisienne par exemple je pense que ce
n'est pas la couche d'une faille dans
laquelle il fallait s'attaquer mais bon
on veut faire des économies partout mais
c'est pas en c'est pas en supprimant les
petites communes qu'on fera des
économies
les élus ruraux sont pas des
carriéristes en politique c'est plutôt
des bénévoles
si je prends le cas de ma commune amer
plus trois adjoints ça doit faire 1300
euros d'indemnités mais pour parler
chiffres donc que nous on est plutôt
tous des passionnés parce qu'on aime
notre village on aime nos habitants faut
aimer les gens rencontrés dans les
communes rurales
donc je pense que c'est une erreur de
vouloir la disparition des communes le
particularisme français des 36700
commune c'est plutôt un atout
c'est une richesse pour notre pays et
c'est pas ça qui coûte à l'état tout le
signe mettetal sur ses angoisses qu'ils
peuvent être exprimés au sein des zones
rurales est ce que ça fonctionne aussi
est ce que c'est vrai aussi en ile de
france dans les yvelines ou alors ça
touche vraiment plus peut-être les zones
rurales de province vous parlez des
andes et traduisent
en terme de vote simple dans ses bottes
ça peut être aussi oui complètement
moi je dirais que c'est l'héritage d'une
histoire dans laquelle on a disqualifié
ces territoires un peu je pense qu'on
est collectivement responsables de les
avoir disqualifié qu'on a assimilé à une
forme de repli sur soi une forme d'entre
eux soit aussi à l'étalement urbain à la
laideur des zones commerciales et cette
disqualification je pense qu'on a
l'héritage il est le résultat est là
aujourd'hui
non je pense était pas justifié on n'a
pas pendant longtemps on n'a pas observé
ces territoires pour eux mêmes on les a
observés par rapport à la ville et la
ville incarné en fait toutes les valeurs
de modernité de mélange de mixité de
densité et le périurbain et rural
incarnait des valeurs négatives je pense
que c'est ça aussi qu'on comporte
aujourd'hui et le fait aussi finalement
d'avoir qualifié les campagnes comme
étant un peu le vide
c'était ça s'est révélé ville qui
incarne l innovation etc et la campagne
c'était le reste là où dans d'autres
pays on a une vision de la campagne de
la ruralité qui est différente
françois le président vous qui êtes
agriculteur bus les agriculteurs ont
connu des problèmes récurrents ces
derniers temps avec beaucoup de
manifestations avaient tous les
problèmes sur les prix sur sur
l'endettement mais elle est aussi ce
sentiment parfois qui ressortait que
qu'aujourd'hui on était moralement il y
avait une baisse du moral que les
agriculteurs ne représentait plus grand
chose aujourd'hui dans l'activité
économique française
est ce que c'est vrai ce sentiment
d'abandon ceux qui font la vie dans les
zones rurales où j'ai enfin faut pas
oublier une chose c'est que dans les
yvelines la première production agricole
c'est la céréale donc il ya quand même
une production de masse importante dans
ce département qu'il faut pas négliger
il faut absolument bien entendu c'est un
atout d'avoir de la population qui
arrive parce qu'il ya de la vente
directe qui peut se faire on attend
aussi des communes de pouvoir s'en
allait forcément sur le bio qui est fait
partie de l'agriculture
des yvelines mais aussi de l'agriculture
de proximité que nos cantines puisse
aussi en bénéficier
donc on fait venir des fois des choses
de très loin alors qu'on a des choses
qui sont produites sur place pour en
revenir sur le logement tout à l'heure
un des inconvénients que nous avons nous
en agriculture c'est de pouvoir loger
les gens qui ont des salaires modestes
qui sont au smic sur nos communes parce
que c'est inabordable donc souvent les
gens font 50 km donc on remet ces gens
là s'ils vont se loger dans le fin fond
de l'eure-et-loir donc ces gens là se
remette sur la route en voiture ce qui
fait que le bilan carbone fin on est
dans un no résout pas le problème parce
qu'on repousse les zones sont repoussés
et on retrouve ces gens-là plus loin et
et ça c'est pas bon pour nous l'autre
souci moi qui me fait très fin qui fait
peur à l'agriculture c'est cette
libéralisation de la loi allure on a des
petites communes qui vont exploser parce
que on peut construire aujourd'hui son
sens surface minimum donc on va avoir
une arrivée de population très
importante d'une populaire des petits
villages 4 500 habitants qui devrait sur
dix en prendre 50 logements quand ils
vont prendre 100 200 sur dix ans ça va
changer tout à fait le tissu de notre
ruralité
pauline vino pour le faire sur ses
angoisses que j'ai exprimée est ce que
et que auquel ont répondu les invités
autour la table est ce que est ce que
les habitants qui viennent vous voir
vous en parle les mères qui viennent
vous voir vous en parle parce que c'est
un sentiment qui est important dans les
yvelines
on l'a ressenti dans l'amont la
consultation convient de mener c'est je
crois que c'est aussi très lié aux
problèmes et aux problèmes d'isolement
ce sentiment de délaissement et d'oubli
l'isolément qui élit qui est liée aux
trans de sujets qui sont sortis dans nos
assises les transports et le
numérique entre autres c'est lié aussi à
la disparition des commerces de
proximité
mais après j'ai envie de dire c'est
aussi un deal avec les habitants on a
d'une part des habitants qui nous disent
il faut plus de commerces de proximité
mais les commerces de proximité pour
qu'ils vivent
il faut que les mêmes habitants à les
faire vivre la santé dans dix ans on est
dans une espèce de paris mais je pense
que les assises ont aussi cette vertu
pédagogique on et non dans une espèce de
contradiction permanente avec des
demandes
et oui évidemment les petits commerces
peu vive mais encore faut-il que les
gens qui les réclament
aïe se fournira pas sinon ça pourrait
faire plus de fun et plus de pédagogie
alors je lance dure aux gens parce qu'il
est lâchement sur cette question
revienne la pédagogie à faire et puis un
peu de bon sens a retrouvé de la part
des habitants nous on est tout à fait
disposée au niveau du département à
aider au maintien des petits commerces
d'ailleurs ça fait partie des annonces
qu'on apportait il regagna quinze jours
au moment de la restitution de nos
assises de la ruralité mais on va pas on
va pas subventionner des coquilles vides
il faut que les gens aillent se fournit
en a pas et que les habitants des
territoires jouent le jeu s'ils veulent
le maintien du petit commerce ils ont
aussi leur part de responsabilité pour
prendre l'exemple du petit commerce
le message est passé ce sera le mot de
la fin c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous quatre dit avoir participer
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast sur tv fil 78 points comme bonne
soirée à tous